okay hi welcome
hey Norwegians
hi welcome
[Music]
hey
um
how many of you know the TV show the
long way around
almost no one
I thought it's a brilliant joke
um
so it's basically
um about two guys one of them is you and
McGregor you know Obi-Wan Kenobi and
they take the bicycle from London to Los
Angeles but they're going eastwards
okay so they're choosing the longest
possible route they could find to get to
their goal and when you look at oauth
and this thing called proof of
possession tokens it feels exactly the
same way okay so proof possession is a
security feature of oauth and if you
don't know what it means don't worry
we're gonna explain it and if you know
what it means you probably know oh
that's kind of complicated
and um
and it took almost 10 years right I mean
oauth was 2011-ish or something and uh
and now 10 years later that we finally
have a workable solution to this thing
called proof possession tokens uh which
you know
close the gap I think in the whole
security model
of oauth okay so that's kind of like um
the the topic
um so I'm here with my good friend
Steiner
um hello
we uh we work together
um on on that and and other things
um
and
many of that is directly related so if
you're from Norway to you know to to how
things work in Norway
um actually by the way the most
important link here is the link to the
slides so you know all the slides are
uploaded already so you know no need to
take pictures all the time of the of the
slides and they're all there for you and
you can um
um download them okay so yeah so I'm
basically uh
it feels like for since my whole life
I'm talking about this kind of
um but the last 15 years or so I've been
working on over the connect and you know
wrote a token server or free or maybe
more
um and you know it's kind of like
and near India to my heart topic and who
are you Steiner yeah hi I'm stainless I
hope none of you thought that the topic
was about concealing in drugs that could
also be a sort of interpretation so uh
anyway I'm staying light I I've
I used to be a developer so I uh don't
do a lot of development anymore but I
work for the health sector and I've been
doing that for many years now uh so the
reason why we are talking about oauth in
the health sector is because
they are actually modernizing a lot of
the technology and they're starting to
use
new modern uh or semi-modern ways of
authentication and securing services so
um
yeah so the reason we met is basically
because of this big project you're doing
in Norway about
uh kind of modernizing the health sector
right and part of that is moving to
overworth and openly connect and and all
of these Technologies
um and you know like when oauth was
designed 10 years ago or so
probably they didn't anticipate that it
became the would become the popular
right so the the original use case of
like you know like the classic canonical
use case of how can you connect a third
party to your Google calendar kind of
thing yeah was nice but now it's used in
healthcare in banking in the military
and basically everywhere right and um so
there's this movement towards a higher
security oauth version so to speak so so
you have the base RCS and then lots of
stuff layers on top of that and there
are multiple uh independent initiatives
worldwide that try to create a more
secure profile for oauth right and some
of them you can see here psd2 is that
the per the payment service directive
too which is a you know like a banking
thing
um fappy which stands for financial apis
or they'll later rename it to financial
grade apis yeah something that needs as
much security as the finance industry so
to speak
um in in the states there's stuff going
on about Enterprise
profiles of oauth and one of the missing
pieces was always proof of position
exactly yeah and that's why we're here
yes okay
so
um
yeah so just a quick agenda so you can
still leave the room if you think that's
boring or something
um we want to quickly talk about the
status quo which is better tokens in
oauth and what are they missing and what
approved possession tokens in in
contrast give you some history
reasons why stuff is happening now right
and then we're going to talk about the
two technologies that you could use
today to to implement this feature okay
so
who is using Olaf
everyone does exactly right and that's
how it works right you get a token from
an hour of authorization server and then
you send the token to the API to call
the API easy and that was exactly the
design goal of oauth to make it as easy
as possible right
um but there's this little thing here
called Pera tokens yeah and what Bearer
tokens means is that whoever
owns the token can call the API so in
other words the only thing that you need
to call the API is is having that token
right
um again it works right but it kind of
assumes
um an Ideal World it assumes that every
single piece in that oau of conversation
is perfectly secure
right the authorization server does not
leak the token the client does not leak
the token the transport is perfectly
secure from eavesdropping men in the
middle attacks uh you're not as I said
leaking tokens into log files or URLs or
you know because anyone who could access
that could take the token and call the
API and impersonate the client right
um
or even uh if if you never thought about
this what about the API the API even you
know like you're sending the token to
the API the API could take the token
turn around and call another API using
the token
right because all it needs is
the being the bearer of the token that's
where the name comes from ma'am
um
and
that seems a little bit risky
yeah so um who has done W security
yeah
um I did right and a lot of it and uh
I actually could even remember how it
worked while writing the talk
um and that that's from 2004. that
that's kind of like before the oauth
wave right and if you read those
specifications I mean that was serious
Enterprise stuff right IBM Microsoft Sun
very sign I mean that these specs were
no place for humor I can tell you yeah
no chokes in those specs yeah
um and they've their job was to write
specs to secure the Enterprise right and
right from the start they assume the
Enterprise needs a lot of security and
also seeing that it's from 2004 uh
imagine 2004 TLS was not widely deployed
right especially not in the Enterprise
yeah
so yeah so that their mission was to to
create something secure so just to give
you a quick rundown
um of how double a proof possession
worked in W security oh yeah and I
forgot maybe to define the term proof
possession basically what they mean with
proof of possession is is that unlike a
bearer token only the client that
requested the token in the first place
can actually use the token
okay so in the proof for session
scenario if if an attacker would get the
token from the wire or from a log file
they would not be able to use that token
so how does it work yeah
um and you will see that there's a
common pattern here regardless of which
technology we're looking at they almost
look similar yeah but um
a little bit different
so um in W security and that is 15
20 years ago okay almost
the way this worked is the client
generated a secret okay a key okay and
then the client made a WS trust request
if you remember WS trust yeah the good
stuff
um to the STS and encrypted that secret
with the public key of the STS so now
even if you could read the wire you
could not see the secret because it was
encrypted with the public key of the SDS
now what the STS did then is it
responded with a saml token
and that saml token contained the secret
that got sent by the client of course
you cannot just send a saml token over
the wire now because the wire is
insecure by definition so the saml token
needs to be encrypted with the public
key of the XML web service
yeah okay cool and then the last thing
would be that the client is now calling
the service sends along the encrypted
sample token and signs the XML envelope
or body or parts of it or you know there
are many variations with the secret
okay so now the service is expected to
decrypt the thermal token get the secret
out of the symbol token and then
validate the signature of the XML
envelope and only if they match up the
client has proven that it's the same
client that asked for the token in the
first place
right
now
what was the big problem here with this
approach
cryptography
right because the client needed to know
up front the public key of the STS
the STS needed to know up front the
public key of the XML web service right
the whole Key Management became a
nightmare
yeah and now throw in key rotation have
you ever seen key rotation in the wild
yeah
there's a reason for that because it's
hard okay so now imagine everyone here
would would rotate Keys every year 10
days
right uh all of that overhead so this uh
while this so did anyone do WCF
poor souls yeah you had like a long
config file with tons of public keys in
there right and they were not just
regular public keys they were x509
certificates of course because that was
the thing by the time right they had you
had to throw in a pki and you know some
other stuff Okay cool so that's how it
works and you know in theory that did
work yeah
um
but still this was going over plain text
HTTP right so lots of opportunity to
mess around with packages and replace
signatures and blah so particularly
another spec on top of that called WS
secure conversation to make it even more
complicated
which basically meant that there was a
negotiation phase in the beginning where
they
created a session key and
anyways you know it it did work
if you could guarantee that the client
stack and the server stack are the same
like wsf for example but that that was
far from being interoperable of course
okay so then came oauth what about oauth
um actually over of 1.0 had the very
best intentions uh the guy who wrote the
spec
Aaron hammer
he looked at w security he hated WS
security uh there were some interviews
where he often says like the spec is as
bad as WS security
um so um but so so he hated XML he hated
soap he hated all of that stuff but he
liked the idea of binding the token to
the client so there he made a signature
bound tokens that default and pretty
much the only option of 1.0
now now if you look at the spec
for over 1.0 here's the section 3.4
signatures
okay and it talks about how how to
create a signature first you need to
create a string then you need to
normalize that string it looks a little
bit like this and then you need to
create a base URI you need to
canonicalize that URI you need to put in
the parameters and the query strings you
sort them by alphabet and
and so on and 10 pages later you end up
with this
okay
um
and five pages later you end up with
that and then you have to do it for
every single API call
okay so while this was possible with you
know
um
it was complicated yeah
so when um over of two got became a
thing right so o of one became popular
but many people said the signature part
is too hard
what can we do about it right so what
did oauth 2.1 do so and the other thing
is of course yeah
um Aaron Hammer was the only spec writer
so he could do whatever he wants yeah he
wrote that spec that was his
um security Vision how it should work
but in all of two companies came in
backpack you know like all of the XML
web guys came back like Microsoft and
IBM and Google and everybody thought
like oh yeah that's good but it's too
hard
can we fix the signature thing how about
we remove it
okay so basically
um in 0 of 2 they removed all of the
signature stuff from the spec again and
came with a new idea
called Barrel tokens okay so what about
we don't do this again it's a couple of
years later right TLS is now pretty much
a given so you don't have to fight
against the fact that your transport is
insecure so they said okay why maybe oh
maybe better tokens are good enough
yeah and Aaron if you ever followed that
history he hated that
he actually a couple of uh years later
he
withdrew his name from the RFC document
okay so he said no I'm not
I'm not giving my name away for an
Enterprise version of oauth where the
big players
simplify it up to a point where it's too
dumb to be secure
okay he was a bit over exaggerating
maybe but on paper Bearer tokens are
less secured and signature bound tokens
I mean that's just the fact of life yeah
and he made a big thing about him
leaving oauth he created things like
this
laughs
um he had a really popular talk at the
conference
um where he coined a new hashtag that
you should use on the internet
and you know ultimately he left
okay
so that's that
um one last thing he did before he left
he said okay I demand one thing you are
gonna split up the overalls back into
two specifications one is how to acquire
a token and one is how to use a token
okay and if you only know today that
you're going to do Bearer then in the
future I want you to create another spec
called proof possession usage
and it never happened
okay so that's
2012 yeah and that spec was never
created afterwards ma'am
um
there were some attempts to to add proof
of possession to oauth
um a couple of years later there was a
spec how to do a server to client key
distribution and and that that's the
easy part right but the hard part is
then once you have that token how do you
bind it to the client
cryptographically and guess what they
came up with a method for signing HTTP
requests and if I would open that spec
up it would pretty much look the same as
o of 1.0 like take the URL take the
parameters take the body canonicalize it
sign it blah blah blah blah okay and
there were fundamental problems there
like you couldn't do HTTP streaming for
example because how would you sign a
stream for example and other things yeah
so it didn't happen okay
uh the only thing that that was left was
a spec that's basically said let's let's
imagine we would have proof of
possession how would the Json web token
look like
but we don't have it so I don't know um
but let's let's put it out there okay uh
everybody was hoping
given the fundamental problems with that
like streaming and other things that
maybe we could solve the problem at the
transport layer right that's where when
they came up with another attempt a
couple of years later called token
binding does anyone remember token
binding
it was basically
an extension to the TLs protocol that
you could basically embed a a unique TLS
Channel key into the token and then bind
the token to the TLs Channel
it worked wonderfully
it did work up until
Google decided to not implement it
so now you have to ask yourself how
useful is a web standard if the biggest
browser is not going to support it
right so that was that did they actually
keep a version of that in the edge for a
while or in the Microsoft
it was removed from chromium yeah right
even that page is not online anymore
that's archive.org is your friend if
you're searching for all of that it's
all gone basically but basically what
the guy says is well we have this token
binding feature here it's not getting
enough traction so I'm just going to
remove it
that's it right many speculations why
Google did that they never gave an
official explanation
uh I guess they had their reasons
performance was one of them we heard
that the performance of you know like
let's say you are a company that that
relies on that your web web page shows
up as quickly as possible in every
browser on the world like a search page
for example
and that is now more complicated and now
it takes like a half a second longer
maybe we don't want that anyways that's
a pure speculation
okay
um
good so that was off the table as well
huh and now a couple of years later what
happened is this RP thing right so far P
stands for as it did stand for uh
Financial apis
Yeah so basically the idea was okay now
Banks start using oauth we need
something more secure than the standard
oauth and funnily enough right people
said okay in if you want to um basically
they said like Banks must Implement far
P or psd2 by the end of was it 2020 or
2019 I think it was September 2019 yes
and you weren't allowed to play if you
didn't so so basically what they said is
and the only way to be far Peak
compliant is you have to use proof
possession tokens
which didn't exist
okay so for that that's a slide from a
guy Ned sakamura you know famous guy in
the area he says okay and in far P we
all going to move everything to prove
possession
now
so that's kind of like when we
started thinking about the the
ramifications for the health industry
right yes and the thing is I mean health
is uh you know primarily about helping
the patients uh but the other
perspective is protecting the patients
and some of that information is quite
sensitive and it can be used in many
different scenarios I mean information
about mental health for instance could
be a nice leverage if you're doing like
negotiations about the fishing rights in
the Northern parts of Norway I know you
know you can imagine uh so the thing is
for health when we start working
together we uh we had a couple of uh
like new implementations coming
some of them are tied to prescriptions
which is by default you know something
you'd want to protect really well but
there are other examples as well it's
like
the national service for registering
deaf
uh if you're able to
kill someone
by using the API uh you know that would
that would be bad basically so yeah and
you fought better tokens are not good
enough for them
[Laughter]
so the thing is what do you do well you
have bear tokens back in the days there
weren't a lot of support for
cryptography for instance it was
difficult to do this in in browsers
Etc so uh
instead of you know in in lack of uh
good Alternatives you do other types of
mitigations you you know we for instance
set the the lifetime of the token to
like one minute perhaps you know make
sure that it's uh Bound in audience Etc
it's uh mitigations mitigation
techniques yeah in in absence of the
technology basically yes but you can
imagine whoever wrote an oauth space
system in his life knows that a one
minute token lifetime is
is not drivable to implement right
especially at scale right when you have
multiple people needing to refresh them
and store them and manage them and and
so on so yeah so one minute is
yeah
I I have many customers even in the not
so critical space which have 10 minute
access tokens for example for exactly
the same reason because they you know
they want to mitigate the the risk when
they leak somehow especially if they
install the software on untrusted
networks like customer networks where
they don't control you know they don't
go to reverse proxies they don't control
firewalls and they're logging and it's
not end-to-end encrypted it's only point
to point in these networks typically
yeah mobile mobile applications same
same problem
yes so but the interesting is now now
that the banks needed it
right so you you could only play that
the PSD psd2 game in the EU if you
implemented that but you couldn't
implement it because there was no
technology for that so now the banks you
know money actually you know Banks
equals money the money came in and the
pressure on the big vendors and on the
ietf and so on and basically okay they
said okay we need to stop Gap solution
now something that we can deploy
immediately
with existing technology and not invent
something new right and that's when they
basically okay
what could we do
and that's where this spec came along
it's basically reusing Mutual TLS
okay so the Assumption was that in many
banks you already have pki and TLS and
smart cards and client certificates and
all of that stuff does already exist
right and we can and you know some some
smart people the offers here they figure
out okay we can use mtls to um to
basically provide a mechanism as it says
to bind access tokens to a client's
Mutual TLS certificate and oauth
protected resources
okay so that was kind of like this the
solution that no one was happy with but
could be produced in a very short amount
of time
ma'am so how does Mitchell TLS work
has anyone ever implemented mtls like
for real
right it's complicated right it's a
complicated Beast that the best um the
best uh explainer video that I found on
the internet is this one here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay but in essence in mtls you have a
client certificate and you have a server
certificate right the server certificate
is to authenticate the server and then
afterwards the client certificate is
used to authenticate the client and
after successful negotiation they have a
shared secret that they can use then to
encrypt and sign the traffic okay so yes
this does exist it's proven technology
it is deployed in some spaces
um so yeah so let's let's see how proof
possession would work with mtls so you
know it's very similar yeah the client
creates an x509 certificate and a
private key or here there is already one
like you know maybe even even on some
Hardware device for example you know
there are so many options with mtls but
the idea is this okay so like the client
has it has an x549 insert then he opens
an mtls channel so he does mutual
authentication with the STS he sends
along the x509 certificate
once that is validated the token server
can create the hash of the certificate
which is a unique identifier and then
embed the hash into the access token
okay so basically what that means is now
that the client has proven to know the
private key that belongs to the hash of
the public key
okay and then the client just opens
another channel to the API using the
same x509 certificate doing mtls right
and then the API has the third from the
transport Channel it has the access
token with the hash he hashes the
transport Channel third compares the
hashes if they are the same the client
has proven that he knows the secret
and if an attacker would steal the thing
he would miss the x509 certificate which
is you know only known to the client
and then this wouldn't work
okay
um
if you wonder how such an access token
looks like it's um like this right there
there's some JWT stuff and that there's
a special claim that they introduced
it's called CNF or confirmation yeah and
the confirmation means how how can the
client confirm that he knows the secret
and that means x509 thumbprint insha
256.
okay and that's the hash of the the
sha256 hash of the of the x509
certificate
how many.net developers are in the room
okay most of you
um guess what that's the only code that
is needed to create an x509 certificate
on the Fly
I'm not saying it's pretty quote
but you know it's boilerplate code yeah
and in case you wonder what what this
number means this number means client
certificate
[Laughter]
it's an oid
right some people love them
so um you know I mean since you have
some time I I can quickly show you that
um
so here's a version of identity server
that is using mtls and you see once if
you have mtls then in your Discovery
document that doesn't use a element here
called mtls endpoint aliases and they
point to the mtls versions of the
standard oau of endpoints on your token
server right so here's the token
endpoint revocation introspection and
device authorization in this case
um
so
and you see also that typically you have
to have to deploy mtls on a different
domain right and they're just all all
sorts of complexity here definitely
going on at the infrastructure level
um
and then on the client side you first
generate that certificate right that
that's the code I just showed you yeah
that's this thing and then you request
the token
and basically all you need to do when
while requesting the token I love that
projector really nice
um is to to basically bind the client
certificate to your HTTP client right so
here we basically create the Handler put
the third onto the transport and then we
use that HTTP client to request the
token yeah that's how you do mtls
internet
um
then then you have the token
and then you can
call the service right and when calling
the service you're doing the same thing
you are getting a decline use the same
X1 x509 third you add the access token
and then you're calling the API right so
if I would run that
it's not very exciting like all my demos
that there's a token yeah
yeah but you can see that that's the
access token coming back from the token
server and you might not have seen this
before here that that's the CNF claim I
mentioned earlier and that is now
binding the access token to the client
certificate okay and then on on the API
side of course you need to validate this
and in in.net world you would probably
have a middleware running after the
authentication that looks at the third
looks at the token compares the two
values and only if they match the call
gets through okay
so that's mtls
as I said it if your company is already
having a working mtls infrastructure
it's pretty easy to pull off because
they already know how that works right
you have your pki and and all of that
yeah
um the other thing that especially banks
that like is that that this is not some
new hipster stuff yeah it's like mtlers
and pki right I mean these are the
things we do for 20 years now and they
work yeah
um and yeah and I mean I give them that
it's quite nice that there's a wider
range of special Hardware out there to
support this like smart cards and uh um
hsms and you know all of that
specialized Hardware
the cons are exactly the opposite of
that right if you don't have that up and
running it's really hard to get it up
and running the learning curve is quite
steep yeah again pki and so on and
especially for scenarios where you want
to secure mobile applications right
whether the mobile application is
somewhere on the internet and you want
to guarantee that from that somewhere
place you open an mtls channel to your
company server
good luck
okay
um oh yeah and actually you know like
for the for the the spa people out there
this doesn't work in browsers at all
right so it would not help in any way
for that kind of
scenario
so what's the alternative
uh
there's a new spec yeah it's basically
um in instead of trying to do this at
the transport level it's trying to do it
at the application Level meaning you
don't need the mtls pki blah blah blah
blah stuff uh up and running okay it's
called depop it is in the last draft so
the final call as they call it in in the
ITF so it's going to be released very
soon
and um yeah so you know before I hand
over to Steiner to show you all the
nitty-gritty details
um guess what I mean for most parts of
my career I I got away with just free
icons for my PowerPoint slides the
client the token server and the API
right
um but you know same idea right the
client generates a key
um and then it signs something special
called the proof token and we'll show
you how that proof token Works um in a
second and then you know you do a token
request send the proof token along and
the STS replies with an access token and
the proof token is signed so they put
the hash of the public key into the
access token
okay same idea just that you don't have
to use x509 certificates really yeah and
then when you call the API you are
sending along the access token create a
new proof token using the same key pair
and again the API has both artifacts now
and they compare the hashes and if they
match you know
uh that that's good so Steiner how does
that work yeah
uh so yeah
just to to say it this is a really you
know big thing we're really looking
forward to to start using this and and
the thing is that Dominic was talking
about was that when Mutual TLS arrived
everyone was you know well we finally
got the what we call sender constraining
of tokens in place
we can start using and uh their first
experiences was with the dialogue The
Selection dialogues the user had to in
browsers in browsers terrible terrible
and the ITF guy said whoa we can't use
it
and that's why they came up with a depop
spec so it's designed to be simple but
of course it's you know to a certain
degree nothing is simple in this world
but
uh the thing is that it's uh it lets us
so I think the the the term uh sender
Coast training is uh the best sort of
description you can use you're you're
still achieving the same thing as you
did with a mutual TLS you can straining
the token to one client so okay
so
this is uh a request
uh that's a pretty much a standard oauth
token request yeah yeah with one added
artifact here and that's this one is it
the the the no I I don't have to oh okay
good I can point instead okay so this is
this is one new thing so uh it's a new
HTTP header where you put the depop
proof
so remember you you uh you left the
client uh generate the depop proof uh
and uh you put it in the not the
authorization header but the depop
header it's a new thing
uh
and here you see the example of uh depop
proof
uh there are some new uh claims here
um
make special notes of these two
the HTM States the method that this
token will be used for so you can say
post or you know put or whatever
and the h t u is the URL that the token
uh will be valid for
so all these are things that sort of
narrow the scope of course in addition
you have the jti which you will use to
make sure that the depop proof isn't
used several times so a jti is basically
stands for short ID and it's a random
number right it's basically used for
replay attacks so that a server should
not accept the same jti in a given time
window exactly
so this portion is also quite
interesting this is where you have the
public key it's a jwk format
and this is what the authorization
server will use when it does its
calculations on its side
yeah public key unique ID HTTP method
and HTTP URL
so all these are registered in the Iana
so it's a
uh now and you know and the idea is that
that jwk is the public key of the key
pair that the client generated and the
signature on the proof token proved that
the client knows the private key yeah
right
next one yeah
so
here you get uh
an example of what it looks like when
it's uh generated this
let's see this CNF claim uh contains the
JK
difficult to pronounce and it's a hash
of the thumbprint
uh I I love this and it's the basics
before URL encoding of the jwkshar 256
front print of the public key yeah yeah
you know it's obvious yeah
I talked to Dominic and I was afraid
because my you know you have to have a
very highly exercised tongue to be able
to pronounce it like Dominic did so I
can't yeah
all right so this is basically the same
as you know the same claim as we had in
mutual DLS so it's uh it already it
already exists there
uh it's not it's not hard you know I
mean it's it's a simple addition
um so I guess we can perhaps go to the
next one yeah
and then when the client calls the API
you will do the regular
stuff you'll have an authorization well
actually not not exactly the regular one
because remember that always had Bearer
in oauth it it's a new token type now
it's a depop token yes and what that
means is it's an access token bound to a
proof token yeah
and it's it's of course it's bound both
ways so the depop token is a debuff
proof is bound to the access token and
the X token is bound to the debug proof
right so when the client now makes an
API call he needs to generate a proof
token every single time for every call I
mean keep that in mind right if it's not
coming for free
um but this proof token basically looks
pretty much the same right but as
Steiner just said yeah the access token
contains the hash of the public key
which is binding the access token to the
proof token
and the proof token contains the hash of
the access token
yeah so it's bound in both directions
and now you see you have the htu which
is also kind of interesting when you do
the first depop proof it's it points to
the Token endpoint well this one
points to the API endpoint
so it's uh I mean this looks familiar I
guess nothing nothing
too weird about it so a couple of
comments here I think yeah is first of
all
you know like the reason why many of
these earlier specs failed was because
they were so complicated right because
you had to sign the complete HTTP
request and the body and the parameters
and you know and so on so here they
deliberately only sign a subset of the
of the HTTP request okay to not make it
overly complicated they're not selling
the body for example right and and we
have security people in the room is that
a problem
so in theory right you could you could
say huh
um I could exchange the body with the
same post request to the same API
endpoint and the proof token would still
be valid right
why doesn't that work
well it's bound to do it no no no what I
mean here is that's where the jti comes
in right also API of course needs to
make sure that he will never see the
same jti twice
yeah so replay detection
it must be done
okay and how how long should your replay
detection cache be
what do you think how many hours or days
of jtis do you need to check
pun
well there is no expiration time right
it only has the IAT claim the issued ad
claim which tells them when was the
token created and now every API can
create their own policy in saying I'm
only accepting tokens which are not
older than a minute
for example right and for that minute
you're keeping your jti cache
so that you can make sure that you don't
see replayed proof tokens
actually another piece of information
which is kind of interesting is that
Microsoft actually has been using depop
for a while in their products like Azure
uh yeah you know Microsoft is the
company that likes to take pre-release
specs yeah changes them a little bit
and and use them in their products
exactly yeah
so uh but that's that's also the
interesting thing is that they actually
discovered some misusage of this pattern
the or this mechanism so uh they had to
do some extensions based on their uh
experiences and um you know so now
they've sort of
fill the fill the gaps with the in the
spec so yeah so I mean again this year
assumes you're using TLS so the
transport is secure already right it it
says You must sign the HTTP method and
you must sign the HTTP URL but the spec
also says you can sign more parts of the
HTTP request if you want to
right but then you're now getting again
into the whole discussion of does the
HTTP request on the client side look the
same as on the receiving end if the if
there is a reverse proxy who shuffles
around the query string parameters and
you know you can do it you can make it
more complicated but the consensus is
that this is signing enough yeah yeah
and we're happy about because at a
certain point it looked like they were
going to
add a lot of stuff to it but they
managed to keep it simple enough I think
so the point is what's the next slide
here
you don't really use that on the API
site because access tokens are used
several times
sure using this the apis
uh
the Replay for proof for for proof
tokens not not for Access tokens yeah
oh yeah you have to you have to
implement it yeah
you have to at least have a policy for
um the freshness like what's the oldest
issued ad you would accept right
um yeah so um quick quick thing um you
know these days I'm not writing that
much code anymore
but between Christmas and uh New Year's
Eve I found some time to do to prototype
this yeah
um the client-side at least so um
so basically the way in in.net you the
easiest way in.net I found to retrofit
this to an existing system is uh
you know what uh what an um HTTP message
Handler is
in.net.net the HTTP client has an
extensibility infrastructure called an
HP message Handler and you know the the
idea is this here the client creates the
key pair okay in this case an RSA key it
could be an an elliptic curve by the way
these are the only ones you allowed to
use symmetric keys are forbidden which
is good yeah
um and then you're basically just
putting that key pair into your HTTP
message Handler and then you're using
the method changer to make your outbound
HTTP request and then this will
basically for every outgoing request it
will create the proof token and send it
along to the recipient okay
um
and then on the receiving end so to
speak right so imagine starting here is
the API right on on the receiving end
you would extract the proof token from
the incoming request by extracting the
header called depop
and then you know I am getting called
why I get and this is My URL and that's
the access token that came along right
and now you would validate all these
things together and only if that returns
true so to speak
it's a valid request
so you would have to calculate right
calculate that's what the library would
do yeah exactly so so um
you you need to change your code to
implement that that technique right but
I think this is a
an okay way to do it because the impact
is not that big right the only impact
you have or have to think about is uh
what's the lifetime of your key material
do you wanna you know like what's your
notion of a session so to speak I guess
yeah
okay
um
so what's the summary what do you think
well uh I I said I haven't programmed
for a long time but I actually did a
JavaScript implementation of uh depop a
while ago and I was able to do it which
kind of says something because
um yeah so I think it's you know it's uh
it's the way to do it for browser-based
client clients I think it's a very good
uh solution for like native apps or
desktop style apps as well but of course
it's it's more complicated
it's it's you know in you need to handle
your keys you need to to do stuff in a
safe way
uh but the you know the the big big
benefit of this is you don't need the
infrastructure you don't need to have
all the setup uh and the you know the
the regular things that comes with
initial TLS the only downside is that
right now there is no commercial product
that exists that implements it yeah
that's the nature of the spec you know
not being finalized uh we are working on
it and we're going to release it you
know mid next year I guess
um so yeah it's new technology
right um it's
it's been out there for a while and a
couple of companies have implemented
like private implementations like
Microsoft and some other so it works
right but it's it's you know you
couldn't use it today right so you
couldn't walk out of the room and say
like okay I'm going to use depop
because you won't find the
implementation of it at least in.net
okay that maybe in in other places they
they do that right
so I can add actually oh and the last
thing because you mentioned browsers
yeah don't think depop will secure your
JavaScript yeah no
[Laughter]
um
depop and they specifically say that
right at the beginning of the spec it's
not a mitigation technique for
cross-site scripting
right and I'm doing Philips doing a talk
tomorrow morning and I'm doing a talk
afterwards about the back and for
front-end pattern and all of the things
that people can do in the browser you
should come there if you are interested
in why this is not the solution to that
yeah
so the just a quick side note here as
well so we work for the these are my
colleagues here we work for the for the
Norwegian Health Network as consultants
and we are actually mandating the far B
2.0 as technical uh security profile for
using open ID connect and oauth and
we don't have support for Center
constraining we do actually because we
use Dominic's product but it's uh so we
do have neutral TLs but it's
very very difficult to to do so we do
require it but we can't support it as
well
it will take a while but uh it's it's
good intentions I think that's the most
important thing okay so I guess
I get my final words here uh you know
better tokens as we now know have
certain security properties right I mean
the sky hasn't fallen yet yeah because
of Bearer tokens yeah so it I mean
everybody is using them yeah
um it's not that you know there are
risks that you can mitigate with things
like token lifetimes and and other stuff
yeah but uh I'm not saying every single
application out there now needs per
approved possession tokens
okay it doesn't come for free that's my
main point yeah it's not that you just
flip a switch and suddenly everything is
uh is even more secure yeah you've seen
that you have the choice between mtls
which has complexity ID uh transport
layer you have the choice of depop which
has complexity at the application layer
and you need to make up your mind I I
guess at the end of the day as security
guys always like to say it's a matter of
your thread model
okay
any questions
so we have a question there
or any vendor support that can make
Bible to store tokens
using Depot nope
nope
nope nope no please please go to this
gentleman's talk tomorrow morning and
he'll tell you exactly why in in a 60
Minute format
yeah this doesn't change anything the
browser is still
no no no no no no it's a structural
problem that you can't solve in the
browser basically
yeah but if the browser could generate
the uh
yeah sure
yeah
to exercise
you're anyway
[Laughter]
off the Record
laughs
I promising that the girls are good
actually attached the heat up header to
uh requested or something yeah but that
would not solve the code the code
injection problem if the browser would
do it for you then the attacker
injecting the code into your application
can do it as well
like that client and it's the same if
you have cookies
I'm not saying the point to be honest
yeah it's it's and as I said that
there were revisions of the spec where
they thought they could solve the
problem then they got told better partly
by Philip and now the specs says very
clearly this is not
um a counter measure for crosstalk
scripting if you have cross-scripting
attacks depop will not solve that
problem
yeah
yeah it's
yes
no I mean it depends right replay care
maintaining replay caches at scale is
hard
right there are some products on the
server side that make it easier but
ultimately you will always have a little
latency between the moment you're
storing the GTI and the moment it will
be available for someone else to check
right so again it probably must so but
on top of that you have issued ads times
and on top of that you had TLS you know
so these three things together kind of
give you
a much better
place but yeah we replay caching at
Cloud scale is hard right
questions
you can but for the same argument as
people say let's check the access tokens
at the Gateway level yeah you can do it
there are pros and cons for that I think
but that would not solve the
the distributed caching problem
[Music]
because it's up to the a to the receiver
to decide on their own but
[Music]
requirements um they didn't want to do a
so they did want to make it prescriptive
right because now if they would have an
expiration date then the token server
would decide about the policy of the API
right what's the point yeah so it that's
why they said okay let's only put the
creation date in there and the receiver
decides what what's a good creation date
and what's the bad one
[Music]
oh yeah in the Azure portal
Azure portal for example
yeah I mean they're still you know
storing access tokens in the browser and
it's kind of sensitive data as well
right if somebody can
control yourself I mean that you know I
mean so the browser-based applications
are not really a good example because
they they're all insecure at some point
yeah but um yeah I mean everywhere where
it's about a lot of money
right or sensitive data like health
health pii
you know but um
so the I guess the the trade-off here is
right
um ICD pop especially important for
public clients
you know like like let's say your mobile
application running on your phone right
where you are using an untrusted Network
to call an API everywhere between your
phone and and the API somebody could
today intercept better tokens
potentially right depop would help
tremendously with that because the the
mobile app will generate the key pair
only they know the key pair right would
get the token do the depot thing would
be much more secure right for server to
server communication
you know I mean that's already happening
in a data center so you can layer depop
on top of that to get even more security
and some regulations require it right
but for me The Sweet Spot for depop to
be honest is is a native mobile
applications
yes um we didn't mention that because we
didn't want to make it too complicated
but um at the same time the refresh
tokens are getting bound to the deeper
proof as well so basically you have to
show this uh when you're refreshing the
token you have to show again that you
know the private key that was used in
the initial token request before you can
get the refresh token for public clients
at least yeah
please
[Music]
us a large scale of provider
our main mitigation for not having proof
of recession is
short-lived tokens
uh
the price of what we have effect to
having short-lipped tokens
it's a lot of complexity in the
ecosystem you see
over the
so
introducing this will
the security part is wrong but it's also
taking down the complexity the overall
complexity you know all the clients all
the apis
a lot but you're getting new complexity
somewhere else
okay oh question
yeah that's a good question yeah so that
that goes back to my point of saying
like if it's a server to server
communication already which would be the
BFF right and they are happening in the
same Data Center and you know then maybe
I maybe I wouldn't do it unless
you live in a space where it's regulated
yeah yeah it's I mean a lot of those
types of decisions need to be based on
risk assessment yeah but maybe I'm wrong
and I just realized it's recorded yeah
so I don't know
[Laughter]
uh you know
it's a threat modeling thing to be
honest and that's not even a joke
okay then thanks for your time
see you around
oh